hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and what if I told
you that there is a secret connection
between some of the most important and
most mysterious characters in all of One
Piece including kuzan GARP sengoku
Jaguar D Saul and even Shanks this
connection has been hinted at by Oda for
a long time and this could change
everything in one piece as the story
reaches its epic climax there are secret
operatives within the world government
system who are actively working to
destroy it kuzan is a double agent and
Shanks and GARP might be working
together so let's get into it you guys
know the drill if you enjoy our one
piece content and you want to see more
leave a quick like and comment right now
it only takes you a second but it helps
with that YouTube algorithm and if you
are one of the over 50 of people who
watch our videos but haven't subscribed
yet make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications subscribing
is completely free but it really helps
me out a lot finally this video will
contain One Piece manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the recent Egghead Arc we
finally got some massive long-awaited
reveals about vegapunk the void Century
devil fruit and more but one type of
reveal that I found extremely
interesting was the reveal that many
important characters in one piece
actually know each other and have
connections that we were never aware of
until now for example we learned that
vegapunk and Monkey D Dragon actually
knew each other for decades and dragon
even tried to recruit vegapunk into the
Revolutionary Army back when it was just
getting started we also learned that
both of them were acquaintances of
Professor Clover and that they were
infuriated by what the world government
did to O'Hara and if that wasn't enough
we found out that kuzan didn't actually
kill Jaguar D Saul kuzan made it look
like Saul was frozen to death but in
reality kuzan spared Saul's life and
once the world government's forces left
O'Hara Saul's body on froze and he came
back to life however he was definitely
marked by fire in the process Saul then
managed to rescue many forbidden books
that O'Hara's Scholars had sacrificed
themselves to protect and he brought him
to elbaf the homeland of the Giants
later on Dr vegapunk visited elbaf and
read all of these forbidden books and he
most likely met with Saul in person
while he was there so here we have some
very interesting direct connections and
face-to-face meetings between characters
who have been very important in the
world of one piece and who up to this
point have only been on the periphery of
the story but who are now finally
getting their spot in the Limelight and
one of the most interesting of these
characters is former Marine Admiral
aokiji AKA kuzan who after leaving the
Marines apparently decided to join the
ruthless and Machiavellian blue
Blackbeard Pirates but hold on would the
man who we now know spared the lives of
both Robin and Saul at Great risk to
himself and the man who directly
challenged sakazuki in the name of his
ideals really decide to join Blackbeard
and become a villain based on everything
that we know about kuzan so far does he
really strike you as the type of guy who
would follow someone like Blackbeard the
answer is almost certainly no especially
in light of the recent reveals about
Saul in my opinion it is far more likely
that kuzan is a double agent and that he
only joined the Blackbeard pirates in
order to gather intelligence about them
and possibly take them down from the
inside there are other theories of
course like the theory that kuzan and
Blackbeard may actually be related by
blood but if it is true that kuzan is a
double agent then who is he working for
what is he fighting for why is he
risking his life to take down Blackbeard
there are some who believe that the
entire showdown between kuzan and
sakazuki was stayed and that kuzan
leaving the Marines was all part of the
world government's plan to fool
Blackbeard into accepting kuzan into his
crew but I personally don't buy this
Theory I think that kuzan's disagreement
with sakazuki was absolutely genuine it
was a clash between two completely
different World Views and value systems
and the epic battle that they engaged in
on Punk Hazard was certainly real kuzan
hated sakazuki's commitment to the harsh
and brutal ideology of absolute Justice
and he was especially outraged by
sakazuki's destruction of O'Hara so no I
don't think that kuzan is still secretly
loyal to sakazuki who is the current
Fleet admiral of the Marines but if he
is not loyal to the Marines per se then
who is kuzan working for or perhaps I
should say working with where do his
true allegiances lie and what is his
ultimate master plan this brings me to a
very interesting and very mysterious
aspect of the 1p story The Marine
headquartered orders secret special
force sword sword was officially
introduced in chapter 956 but the
undercover captain of sword X Drake was
introduced all the way back in chapter
498. back then he was referred to as the
Fallen Marine because he was a former
rear Admiral who defected from the Navy
and established the Drake Pirates he
then became one of the supernovas and
Allied himself to kaido and became his
subordinate but as we learned in chapter
956 Drake's pirate life was a lie
because he was an undercover marine
officer all along in that chapter we see
Drake secretly communicating with Kobe
who is also revealed to be a member of
Sword Drake shares valuable Intel about
what's happening in mono and from the
brief conversation between the two we
learned two important things first Kobe
is careful so that no one will hear his
conversation with Drake even though he
is on board a Navy ship which confirms
that even the vast majority of the
Marines don't seem to know that sword
even exists this makes sense of course
since Drake's entire Mission depends on
everyone believing that he really
defected from the Marines but Kobe's
extreme secrecy confirms this further he
and Drake even use a code word in order
to confirm that the communication is
secure on both sides the second thing
that we learned is that Kobe had no idea
that members of cp0 were present on wano
so that confirms that there is no
coordination or meaningful communication
between cp0 and so on since we know that
cp0 is under the direct command of the
celestial dragons the lack of
communication between them and sword
pretty much confirms that sword is not
under the command of the world Nobles
remember this part because it will be
extremely important later in chapter
1032 we see that the cp0 agent who wears
a bowler hat is actually aware of
Drake's secret identity although Drake
didn't necessarily know that cp0 knew
this which again suggests that sword
keeps its Mission secret even from cp0
itself or at least they tried to
although in this case they seem to have
failed this is all extremely interesting
because even though they are both secret
agencies that are technically on the
same side they are much closer to being
Rivals than allies they don't share
Intel with each other in fact they try
to keep their missions hidden from each
other to the point that they may even
end up in the same location and fighting
against each other as was the case on
wano if cp0 and sword are Rivals and if
cp0 is under the direct command of the
world Nobles the rulers of the world
government then who created sword and
what is its true Mission our sword and
cp0 really on the same side the side of
the world government system of which the
Marines are apart or are they actually
enemies who want completely different
things let's look at the known members
of solar they include Captain x-ray rear
Admiral Prince groose Captain Kobe
Commander hebari Lieutenant Commander
helmeppo and four other members who
haven't been named yet but that can't be
all can it and I'm not talking about
other minor and as of yet unnamed
members I'm talking about the leadership
of Sword there is no way that this
powerful top secret organization was
established by Drake alone a man who is
clearly a field agent he went out on a
dangerous undercover mission for an
extended period of time so he clearly
wasn't the one giving out orders from
headquarters this means that there has
to be someone else who is behind the
establishment of sword and who is in a
position to actually command and
coordinate the operations of the entire
agency in my opinion the top candidates
for being the true leader or leaders of
Sword include kuzan fujitora GARP and
sengoku smoker is also a potential
candidate but he's definitely not my Top
Choice in one of his recent videos
grandline review pointed out that smoker
doesn't seem to know much about kuzan's
movements so it's likely that if smoker
is a member of Sword then koozan isn't
and vice versa in fact grandline
believes that the leader of Sword has to
be either kuzan or fujitora and there
are multiple reasons for this I will
link that video down in the description
because it makes some great points now
of course we know that fujitora dislikes
the world government he has openly
disobeyed them before and he even
orchestrated the destruction of the
warlord system seemingly without
clearance from up above that said
fujitora is believed to have joined the
Marines only two years ago and sword
must have been around for longer than
that so what about kuzan could he be a
secret double agent and the shadow
commander of Sword I mean it's certainly
possible since we know that kuzan has
been an influential Marine for decades
we know that the Ohara incident upset
him and changed him as a person and we
know that he is clearly willing to defy
the will of the world government he
chose to spare the lives of both Robin
and Saul at Great risk to himself and he
even tried to challenge sakazuki for the
position of Fleet Admiral in fact we
know that kuzan was the more popular
choice for Fleet Admiral among the rank
and file Navy officers so that again
speaks to the immense influence that he
has within the organization we also know
that kuzan's original motto wasn't
actually lazy Justice initially his
model was burning Justice which suggests
the opposite of a lazy and laid-back
attitude towards Justice however over
time kuzan's perspective changed
probably after he became disillusioned
with the world government and its
actions especially in light of the
Buster call on O'Hara and so as we are
led to believe after seeing that the
world government and people like
sakazuki have a completely different
understanding of Justice from his own
kuzan concluded that Justice was
relative and he decided to take a
laid-back and lazy approach to it but
this could all be just a facade that has
been expertly perpetuated by kuzan over
the course of many years what if koozan
didn't really change his approach to
Justice what if he decided to secretly
pursue burning Justice while putting up
a lazy front in order to avoid unwanted
attention from the world government so
while publicly kuzan pretended to be
laid back secretly he established sword
and continued to pursue his true vision
of burning Justice through his special
secret organization eventually when
sword was already established and
functioning on its own kuzan decided to
go undercover and Infiltrate The the
Blackbeard Pirates why exactly he did
this is still not known to us but it
could all be a part of his master plan
after all the Blackbeard Pirate just
kidnapped our boy Colby who is a
confirmed member of Sword so we are
likely about to see a face-to-face
encounter between kuzan and Kobe this
would be the perfect opportunity for Oda
to reveal that kuzan is secretly
affiliated with sword and that he and
Kobe are actually on the same side so
I'll be watching closely for that
encounter personally I do like this
Theory because there is something
clearly going on with kuza he obviously
has strong moral values and he
disapproves of blatantly unjust acts
like the destruction of wahara he is
also willing to openly defy the world
government by sparing the lives of
individuals like Robin and Saul
individuals who the world government
wanted eliminated at all costs and yet
after clearly showing himself to be a
moral and principled Guy kuzan just
decides to join the most amoral crew in
all of One Piece that definitely doesn't
make sense unless this is all a part of
some secret infiltration scheme but
although I think that kuzan is
definitely affiliated with sword in some
way we can't say for sure that he
himself is the leader or the only leader
that's because we still can't rule out
other influential members of the Old
Guard such as GARP and sengoku in his
video Grand line kind of dismisses the
possibility that GARP or sengoku could
be the leaders behind sword because they
are old and practically retired at this
point I will have to disagree here
because I think there is a lot more yet
to be revealed about these guys their
character arcs are not yet complete and
one or both of them could be behind
sword first let's talk about sengoku
because he actually has a direct
connection to the most important member
of sword that we know to date X Drake we
know that sengoku took in Don Quixote
rosinante when he was still a child and
raised him as his own son rosinante then
Rose to the rank of marine commander and
sengoku tasked him with spying on the
Don Quixote Pirates Who were led by his
older brother doflamingo but what a lot
of people don't seem to know and what we
learned thanks to some Vira card
information is that after he escaped
from his pirate father X Drake was found
by sengoku himself and taken in by the
Marines Drake eventually Rose to the
rank of rear Admiral before going
undercover to spy on the Beast pirates
in a very similar way that rosinante
went to infiltrate the Don Quixote
Pirates now multiple online sources
including the official one-piece Wiki
state that X Drake was taken in by
sengoku and raised as his son in exactly
the same way that rosinante was while
this is possible it is not technically
confirmed I checked with our tour from
the library of O'Hara website and
YouTube channel and he explained that
sengoku found the Drake picked him up
and assigned him to Marine headquarters
but the alleged father-son relationship
is not confirmed not even on the Weaver
cards I mean it could be a father-son
relationship but we have to acknowledge
that we don't have that official
confirmation even though some sources
have claimed that we already do oh and
definitely check out Arthur's Channel he
is incredibly knowledgeable about every
little detail of One Piece Link in the
description so considering the fact that
there is clearly a direct connection
between sengoku and Drake and
considering that the two of them have
known each other ever since Drake first
joined the Marines we certainly can't
rule out that sengoku may be affiliated
with sword this becomes even more
blatantly obvious if the two of them
really did have a father-son
relationship like sengoku and rosinante
and then Drake just happens to end up
with an undercover pirate Mission very
similar to the one that rosinante was
assigned to by sengoku himself if that
father-son relationship is ever
confirmed it will be almost impossible
to imagine that sengoku isn't the one
behind sword or at least that he has
isn't one of its leaders after all
sengoku's dislike for the world
government is well known he nominated
kuzan to become Fleet Admiral over
sakazuki and in general he has become
more and more disillusioned with the
ruling regime over the years to the
point that he decided to resign from the
Marines altogether and although sengoku
is a great candidate for being the
leader or one of the leaders of Sword I
think that an even better candidate is
none other than the hero of the Marines
Monkey D GARP himself GARP is of course
part of the same generation as sengoku
but his opposition to the world Nobles
is even more pronounced than sengokus
GARP flat out refused to be promoted to
Admiral despite being offered the
promotion multiple times because
Admirals are under the direct command of
the Celestial Dragon and GARP absolutely
refuses to operate under their command
what's more GARP actually expressed
embarrassment over the fact that he
fought to protect the celestial dragons
during the infamous God Valley incident
protecting the world Nobles should be
seen as a top priority by every
prominent member of the Navy and yet
GARP dislikes the world Nobles so much
that he doesn't want anyone to know that
he protected them GARP also tried to
resign from the Marines along with
sengoku but he was practically forced to
stay on as someone who trains the next
generation of Marines because his and
sengoku's resignations would have been
really bad PR for the world government
and when we really think about it GARP
is someone with very close connections
to people who willfully operate outside
the law including wanted criminals like
Curly the Don oh the leader of the
Revolutionary Army just happens to be
his son oh and he secretly did a favor
for the former pirate king gold D Roger
by protecting his son Ace from the world
government yes the same world government
that GARP is apparently supposed to be
serving then there's the fact that Kobe
and helmeppo were personally mentored by
Garb and trained to become Marines under
his supervision only a couple of short
years later both of them were confirmed
to be members of Sword is that a
coincidence I sincerely doubt it GARP is
a character who still hasn't been fully
fleshed out his character Arc is
definitely not complete and I'm almost
certain that we will learn more about
the God Valley incident before the story
comes to an end an incident in which
GARP played a leading role so I believe
that GARP is absolutely affiliated with
sword and in fact he's likely one of its
leaders the true beginnings of Sword May
date all the way back to the god Valley
incident and once we finally get that
flashback ever everything will begin to
fall into place this brings me to
another fascinating character that I
think may be secretly affiliated with
sword and that is red-haired Shanks now
of course I don't think that Shanks is a
member or leader of Sword but I do think
that he might be some kind of affiliate
because there are some suspicious
circumstances surrounding Shanks that
need to be explored further for one
thing we now know that Shanks was
actually on God Valley as a baby and
that is where Roger found him and took
him in as a member of his crew GARP was
also there at the same time and fighting
alongside Roger so it is quite possible
that GARP has known Shanks since he was
literally a toddler then there's the
little matter of how exactly Shanks and
the red hair Pirates discovered the top
secret location of the gomungomunomi 13
years ago this devil fruit was being
carefully guarded by cp9 and it was
being secretly transported aboard a
government ship and yet the red hair
Pirates found it attacked the ship and
stole the devil fruit this very devil
fruit would later turn out to be The
Godly mythical Zone devil fruit known as
the hitohitonomi model Nika the same
devil fruit that once belonged to the
legendary Joy boy himself wow what a
crazy coincidence I wouldn't be
surprised if Shanks and the red-haired
Pirates were actually tipped off about
the top secret location of the
gomugomonomi because someone within the
Marines someone who is directly
connected to sword may have contacted
them soon after stealing the
gomogomonomi shanks and his crew arrived
in fuchsia Village and remained there
for over a year that is where they met
young Luffy who eventually ended up
accidentally eating the gomogomunomi but
isn't it kind of insane that Shanks who
was by then already a notorious pirate
and someone who directly attacked the
world government in the past decided to
spend over a year off and on in the
hometown of marine vice admiral Monkey D
GARP just drinking and hanging out with
garp's own grandson we have to remember
remember that fuchsia Village is not a
big place it's the kind of place where
everyone knows each other and everyone
talks to each other as soon as someone
like Shanks sailed into town everyone
would be talking about it and even if
they didn't know who he is exactly they
would be able to guess a lot by just
looking at his ship and his crew and yet
we are supposed to believe that Marine
vice admiral Garb the hero of the
Marines had no idea that the notorious
pirate Shanks was using his hometown as
a home base for over a year we are
supposed to believe that GARP didn't
realize that his own grandson Luffy had
befriended these Pirates and was hanging
out with them all the time if GARP
really didn't know this information then
that would make him not only a horrible
grandfather but also a horrible marine
officer the idea that GARP wasn't
collecting basic Intel about what was
going on inside his own Hometown where
his own grandson was seems absolutely
laughable to me and this makes me think
that GARP actually knew a lot more than
he let on in the past GARP has stated
that he hates Shanks because he blames
him for corrupting Luffy and setting him
on the path to becoming a pirate but his
hatred for Shanks could be just a cover
after all a young Ace just happened to
be there near fuchsia Village at the
same time that Shanks was there and Ace
just happens to be the only son of
Shanks as former Captain Goldie Roger oh
yeah and he just happens to have been
secretly taken into the care of GARP in
direct Defiance of the world
government's orders there just seems to
be too much coincidence here and I
believe that once we get the truth about
God Valley and garb's backstory we will
also learn a lot more about Shanks about
kuzan and about sword it's all connected
and it will all be revealed in the final
Saga of the story so with all of that
said what is sword anyway there are
those who believe that sword was created
by Marines who hate the world Nobles as
a secret organization whose purpose is
to overthrow the world Nobles from the
inside but that doesn't seem to be the
case because it has been implied that
cp0 is aware of sword's existence if
sword really was determined to literally
overthrow the celestial dragons we can
assume that tp-0 would have tried to
eliminate everyone associated with sword
a long time ago but even if sword isn't
actually some sort of revolutionary
secret organization it could still be
used for revolutionary purposes even if
sword was created by people like GARP
with a more humble purpose like for
example advancing the cause of True
Justice in the face of world government
Injustice and hypocrisy sword can easily
grow into a revolutionary organization
once the final war between the straw hat
Grand Fleet and the world government
erupts sword has important connections
within the Navy it has spies among the
Pirates and it is likely affiliated with
key figures like GARP kuzan and Shanks
among others as such sword could play a
major role in the final battle and
members of Sword could make up the core
of the new Navy command once the world
government is overthrown and a new Freer
world is created I believe that this is
exactly what Oda is planning to do with
sword and I think that he has been
planning all of this for a very long
time it's only a matter of time before
the shocking truth is revealed what do
you guys think who is the real leader of
sword and what is its secret purpose is
kuzan involved is GARP involved is
Shanks involved let me know down below
if you're looking for another one-piece
video to watch right now check out my
video on the secret former user of the
gomugomonomi who was already revealed in
chapter 550 of the manga Link in the
description and don't forget to leave a
like and comment if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more and of
course don't forget to subscribe it's
free and it really helps out a lot you
can also hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram at anime uproar as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys